yeah tell me we're alive welcome to the
weekly Bowl oh no I don't have anything
handy to show what we have but as usual
oh you know what I bought the Superman
on Jane deluxe edition because I found
it for seven dollars in Amazon I
normally have comics here to go through
I've read them all for once I'm Benny
the comic story and that is Sal from TV
little house that is Ronald from Marvel
explained and that is a picture of Aris
because he's stuck in a freezer right
now because he's mr. freeze yeah I'm on
my iPad for everyone wondering so
apparently iPads don't have conference
capability to uh to see me so you guys
get to stare at my my lovely avatar for
the next hour so I thought I personally
think that the whole reason behind this
is Aris just didn't want to wear pants
today and he was like it's free you
promised you wouldn't tell them all
right guys so today um as usual we're
having our weekly poll we're continuing
our incursions in which other
accountable channels are smashing
together with us at the end of this we
will probably kill Aris because there's
three of us and one of him so I think we
can survive incursion yeah oh so we're
gonna find a way to push it away did you
bring an affinity gauntlet with you
Varys I did of all the gems right here I
just can't see he's holding [ __ ]
gauntlet right yeah it's currently in
front of the camera but it's not you
can't see me they're good they're about
to power up and everything so today
we're gonna do is we're gonna talk about
three really hot topics guys we're gonna
talk about the new 52 is ending we're
gonna talk about spider-man is lying
leave with the rest of the Avengers and
we'll talk about endgame if there's any
time left over because we've been
postponing it for eras but then news
happened what well I appreciate you guys
waiting for me to talk Batman as uh I
think everyone on the internet knows
that I'm a huge Batman fan
well you're the badness
like the new guys on the block like they
just got here Batman guy I think he's
gonna blow up yes apparently he's
allergic to green rocks how here's that
oh yeah you guys heard about the new
superheroes the flash he's a total
Quicksilver ripoff Oh baby oh is
completely dead and we actually got real
reports on that as usual um can't be
heard it's good thing I intro the
podcast cuz if if we were letting drop
podcast it at least they can hear me I
mean they can't see me but I could hear
me that's right so okay so let you know
well we're off trying to fix that let's
go his air escape to explain run for a
microphone turn the volume turned all
the way down I was uh I was recording
some destiny gameplay earlier so thanks
yeah okay so yeah okay so why don't you
just fill us in real quick on a rundown
what man I'm just gonna saying
everyone's like a father of all of us
but you all are my children
Varian is basically just a complicate on
YouTube and discovery discovery digital
which is basically just we talk about
all things comics so like I do like
origins stuff like history Oz where I
break down characters history from the
creation to the origin yada yada top
five top tens I review video games
movies any latest news like I say in the
show I talk about all things comics so
if it's a comic related I'll talk about
it and that's it in a nutshell like I
said I'm pretty sure everyone here knows
who you are but we'll just cover that
Oh shucks so everyone's calling you
Thanos apparently the call me Thanos
I did say how the Infinity Gauntlet it's
right here you guys just can't see it
alright guys so why don't we start with
the biggest news that everyone has blown
up our Twitter's about like I even made
the joke last night someone's like hey
if you heard about spider-man like six
hours after it happened yeah I'm like oh
you mean that news that he joined Hydra
so why don't we start with that and
Eira's why don't you tell us your
opinions on it I know you just made the
one shot but let's explain it better so
yeah basically I'm super excited I mean
Marvel Studios I think everyone knows
whether you're DC fan image fan whatever
fan I think everyone could agree that
Marvel Studios has been kicking butt
with their movies I mean DC only really
has like what man is steel and then the
dawn of Justice gonna come out which is
gonna be connects to that but as a whole
Marvel Studios is doing a fantastic job
and I think it's gonna be at this point
be really hard for DC to catch up since
they're so far behind especially now
it's like you know I got daredevil Luke
Cage on Netflix which is probably gonna
be incorporated into civil war or some
future Avengers movies since it's in the
same cinematic universe anyway and plus
spider-man like I said in the one-shot I
put up on my channel spider-man is my
favorite Marvel character so this is
just like a dream come true for me
because people are like you didn't like
Andrew Garfield by age girl feel like
Andrew Garfield I'm like amazing
spider-man movies were good but I mean
there was a lot about it that wasn't
good in my opinion you know so whereas
Marvel I'm not saying every Marvel
Studios movie is perfect but as a whole
I think you can say like they're like a
plus you know if you were to leverage
them all together so I think like Kevin
Feige and just Joss Whedon everyone
who's like at the helms of Marvel
Studios Cinematic Universe is gonna do a
great job because if people are like
saying amazing spider-man was great and
there were some really cool scenes was
Ripper now the comic books I'm like yes
so imagine that but at Marvel Studios
hands imagine how much better could be
or even just you know with the writing
and just even the look of it I'm just
super excited I'm like I'm drooling all
over it like a big part of it will be
like imagine a whole movie where
spider-man does things with his mask on
the whole I mean it's exciting man I
mean you know and this is what I this is
what I was so psyched about what are the
funny things is like I waited until
about 7 or 8 a.m. because I figured
that's what all the news networks are
pretty much gonna have all the
information out by then like the ones
who are confirming the one
were waiting on two sources I don't know
why they would need it my were the ones
that came out and said it but
nonetheless you know the one thing we
started looking at stuff and I was
always seeing like clickbait links like
Spider Man to joining the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like see like Sony
doesn't have spider-man anymore stuff
like that and I was like come on guys
but to me like this is a step in the
right direction I mean even if Marvel
only has a hand
even if Marvel is only helping to
produce content for spider-man as part
of Sony when spider-man gets to appear
in a Marvel Cinematic Universe film I
think we all know hands down it's gonna
be Civil War why wouldn't it be I mean
well that that was already the first
rumor going around that it would be good
the first real appearance would be
capped three and it's a great
conveniently that's civilly apparently
the Russo brothers drop that hint like
when they were talking a stirrer Winter
Soldier drop they were like we were
writing this this this story and we have
room for a Marvel character we don't
have the rights to and however you like
really like so confident are you I mean
let's let's say for example the Russos
knew this was gonna happen let's say
that like like having Figgy came to MIT
said look guys like don't go out and say
anything like that is concrete yet but
like we'll have spider-man by the time
civil war comes around if that was the
case I don't know how in God's name they
managed to keep it secret
for me I feel like cuz Amy Pascal was
the content director of Sony and she's
the one who like brought spider-man into
Sony in the first place and I remember
watching an interview with her and like
a VR ad like a couple of years ago and
her saying something like like somebody
made a comment is back before Marvel is
killing it it was like during like The
Incredible Hulk like release and them
saying like hey maybe you know might do
a collaboration or maybe like Marvel
might get spider-man back and any Pascal
gave a quote something like more or less
they will never get spider-man so long
as I'm alive because that's the only
thing she's ever done for Sony that like
because it's a billion-dollar franchise
that she can single-handedly say like it
was mine and I'll like it's the only
thing that she had to like tout and so
like as you probably know like she
departed Sony not a week ago
Oh literally a week later we get this
information and I want to say like the
the buzz over at Sony's Pictures was
just like well bye and they're like so
long hey Mika members called ISTE right
we will make a deal we will make it work
I should see that happening we're having
talks and they fell through that was the
rumor and Sony said like you know
they're old news didn't fell it fell
apart yeah because Amy said no but now
she's gone so oh dude I have no doubt
that was a case I had no doubt that as
especially like once the whole leak
happened and it was like well like you
know Sony wants to reboot spider-man
again and ever like not even just
spider-man fans like or haven't come up
with readers like everybody in the world
was just like oh dear god no yeah II was
just like all right guys we gotta do
something it's not like it's like we're
not in a situation where spider-man's
been doing amazing for Sony and Sony's
been getting such good press its fighter
man hasn't been like the underperforming
movie that everyone's talking about how
amazing it is if only people would go
watch it like it's a written written on
the wall since the first amazing
spider-man and everyone's like all right
we're gonna give you one more chance
Sony
well it's amazing
the Disney has the amount of like lawyer
power they have I feel like if sinister
six came out or if their female-driven
leading spider-man character movie that
they hadn't announced yet was released
and it made like crap I feel like Disney
would have just been like a screw just
use them just use them and then like
have some let him sue us well just keep
it keep it going okay poor Disney we
should pay any could you imagine that
what if we got bad news Disney Sony
wouldn't give up spider-man so Disney
bought them April Fool's page was going
around and people were like like Disney
buys or I guess Morrow buys the rights
back to the X
like eight billion dollars I'm like look
guys this isn't impossible yeah it was
actually more than that was x-men
spider-man and something else and I was
like and Fantastic Four and I'm like
yeah I'm like yeah that sucks but like
you know what that sounds like real not
real like real numbers that Disney would
you it's and this that's what I want to
see I want to see like a meeting with
Sony executives and I want to see the
light oh I don't even want to see Bob
Iger show up there or even if he does
like I want to see like meeting I want
to see this meeting take place and the
people walk in and they say so what's it
gonna take to get the Spider Man back
and they're like well I mean you know
we're kind of hesitant so like he just
breaks out a checkbook and he's like
give me a number the funny thing is like
the deal they have it's amazing how over
a barrel Sony had been after amazing
spider-man 2 and yet
the deal they have is so incredibly
sweet because didn't because Sony gets
final saying creative control of the
character so when he gets to distribute
and earn the profits from the spider-man
movies so Disney gets to make them like
Disney gets to do all the work and so he
gets to get money for not doing anything
before effectively screwing it up which
is like fine you know what if Sony wants
to have creative control over the end
like we all know what that means like we
all know that well yeah it looks good
okay yeah cuz I've actually ever since
the initial stuff came out I would I've
heard a thousand rumors and I I wanted
to come into the weekly pull being a
little kind of like like undereducated
as to the actual terms of the whole
thing so what is the actual terms to
determine that the actual terms of the
whole spider-man thing is that Kevin
Feige and Amy Pascal will be the
creative team behind spider-man they're
gonna be the ones that are basically
gonna be the creative team behind the
Sony release of the spider-man stories
now in response to this marvel's going
to be able to include spider-man in a
Marvel Cinematic Universe and over their
choice now we don't know if it's just
one right now they said it's one film
but it won't just be one but why what I
almost expects like for the next I don't
know 10 Marvel movies the n bumper cameo
is going to be something
evolving spider-man that's the rumor
going around right now for age of Ultron
they're saying that you know that it's
scram Marvel scrambling around to put a
spider-man Easter Egg at the end of the
movie you could just put a dude in a
costume and have a Malayan that's all
you need all that has to be like we get
to the ending and you see like the
destruction of wherever they fought it
or whatever
and you just all you need to do is have
spider-man swing in and land be like I'm
late yeah I mean it's not even what I
want to see that's not even what I want
to see here's here's how I want this to
play out all right
like imagine if you will because I've
been thinking about this for hours
visionary when it comes to these things
let me paint you a picture imagine that
like you have the the credits rolling
alright the credits end for age of
Ultron the screen goes black for like
ten seconds alright and then before you
actually see anything you hear a voice
talking and it sounds like an instructor
or a teacher or something like that
alright obviously this is the person
like the scientist who was in the I
guess the to wherever it was I was
talking to Peter Parker when he was in
high school and he had gone to that bad
to tell you whatever was yeah whatever
version you want to use yeah okay I'm
using like amazing fan movie like where
its genetic super spiders that you'd
make for no reason no I'm using I'm
using amazing fantasy number 15 here oh
so it's a radiation so it is irradiated
spider this is this is a whatever they
want to do whatever kind of spider it is
alright so this guy's talking alright
and then like use all you do like the
the scene opens up and you've got a guy
just like standing there and who's just
like scratching his neck I think it just
goes like like that and it stops I'm
pretty sure I'm a huge spider-man fan
just like you I'm loving spider-verse
even though Sal's hating it I love
spider verses much too like spider-verse
have ever done it's just a callback to I
will say this
I'm sorry to Remini but Sal has
awesome alternative to the current run
of spider-verse I do it's I'm not even
if we have time we'll get into it but
what else okay no errors because being
as in it cell to the last thing as a
spider-man that I want to see is even
another just or no more origin no more
no more or the way if we want you know
what we don't even need to cast
spider-man to get a spider-man cameo in
this movie in age of Ultron at the end
of each row Letran you know we need JK
Simmons is Jay jonah Jameson yes we do
yes we do I don't like these heroes are
ruining everything they can be cast they
can recast anybody else they won't do
that because he's too minor of a
character the the non hard core
competence is where the duck ended
Dorian's the galaxy buddy we're trying
to announce that we've got spider-man
they were just like we don't have an
idea some people actually leave before
the end of a Marvel movie
so like I I guarantee you like you could
you could use anybody you could have
black cat if you wanted to and like the
same percentage like 33 percent of the
audience would see it like so use DJ
jonah jameson and the people go oh you
see the spider-man camión people and the
people who don't know would go and see
it or watch the the the bootlegs online
and go who's the weird guy and people
would just be like what are you stupid
like this JJJ like in trust me that
would do the work it would do the work
for you it would set the fires you
needed yeah I mean it's it's like they
could cast sock puppets for the rest of
the characters I don't care but like as
long as I bring JK Simmons back because
he was the perfect JJ Jameson and he
said he has said on record that he'd be
happy to come back yeah in general yeah
he's so good laughing I don't think
about that Coen Brothers movie with The
Ladykillers um if you guys ever had a
chance I don't if you guys have ever
seen it go back and watch Oz on HBO oh
he was amazing
we'll go hang out later and talk about
Howie
I'm down to see that conversation you
guys gonna record it oh by the way
here's somebody chiming in the chat and
they said I like did I miss something
likewise I risked a JPEG so I totally
hear from an alternate earth we're like
I know has JPEG people that's why you
will not win this incursion
well actually makes it we can't see what
they're doing on his iPad isn't
compatible decide which one it's kind of
I saw someone that ask you how old you
were Benny and you're like I'm either 16
or 30 you pick it was funny cuz I think
like I responded was 16 works for me
okay cool that's awesome I don't know
why I remembered that I just thought it
was funny all the time actually cuz I'm
getting a lot of tweets lately with
which superhero do you think is gonna
win the latest was like Captain America
or Black Panther and I just refused to
pick ones always like Captain Panther
and I'm the first guy who's running like
wait who's that no I get it
hold on so bloody signer is Captain
America okay okay I was like I was like
I really think that he's joking here but
I just need to come camera you mean
Falcon right obviously that's going on
on the next what I think is but this
this is bigger news but there's less to
talk about with your spider-man thing
that's the problem because we don't even
know if officially civil wars gonna be
the movie so I think I I think they're
gonna scramble and put something in age
of Ultron I think you imagine iron
spider suit on the big screen yes
because I think because if he is in
Civil War there there's no way you don't
at least you have to use the suit at
that point you cannot put him in you
know what I really when I remember when
they launched it and me and the most
vocal of spider-man fans I was like okay
that looks okay most people were like
that sucks
I love it's grown on me a lot over the
years especially when when it's dead
ones handle my better writer or better
artists I
I don't never who it is but I think it's
actually Michael Turner his version of
the spider suit it looks really cool but
in any case no matter what your opinion
of that suit is seeing it done for real
I think would have the same reaction as
like seeing that Hulkbuster suit oh yeah
it was like him flicking those big like
Talon thingy shooting out of his back
like for real that would yeah I would
blow my mind I'll be like holy crap and
I'm wondering how they would do it would
it be like half practical half CGI
though the iron suit the Iron Man suit
is like half black laughs CGI think yeah
yeah you probably all though at the same
time like he has to move like spider-man
in that thing so probably mostly seal
brother Seiji red man I mean I like the
iron spider soup it wasn't that the big
problem with it like yo he's still
maneuvers like spider-man that makes no
sense why wouldn't you just wear the
fully plated armored suit at all times
pants disabilities yeah any information
about it there was an actual armored one
he made an armored suit like way back in
like the 80s again I mean the spider
armor yes fighter am i silver one yeah
he had one issue holy crab my top 10
spider-man costumes upstairs okay nope
no because the cartoon from the 90s too
though remember when they had like that
little crossover with spider-man Riley
character that was cool
I was she the most developed of that
suit ever
we're like spider-man's a jerk and he's
like an industrialist I like that a lot
well I think it's more so to like I even
said in the episode like it was
nostalgia because yeah I was like in one
issue for like a little bit but to
actually had actions figures for it and
I had all the actors when I was a kid oh
just like it's a silver and black
spider-man suit it looks awesome so I'm
like I'm gonna throw it in there yeah
awesome I mean like they knew how
awesome it was because it was on the
cover and it was like holographic like
me they knew what they were doing well
the thing with that cover is honestly I
mean the reason why it's only two panels
it's the same logic be fun behind um
it's the same logic behind the the Gila
Lantern Batman we're just showed up
briefly just so they get a crap ton of
toys out of it yep well here's here's a
problem here's what here's what I'm
afraid of all right I know that like
since since mama has a creative control
behind they're gonna take in a better
direction because I like them what Sony
did because here's what I think what
Sony did I think that like the Sony
executives were like who should we have
for a villain as spider-man and like the
amazing spider-man if someone's like
hold on I'll double check and they did a
Google search top 10 spider-man villains
videos they said Green Goblin but like
what I'm afraid of is like people are
gonna go into this and they're going to
think that it's going to be like a
Marvel Cinematic Universe film but more
so than that like once we actually get
to like spider-man appearing in the
Civil War if he appears with the iron of
the iron spider suit I think some people
who don't know a lot about comics
especially about like Civil War are
going to get confused and they're gonna
be like why does he look like Iron Man
okay he's gonna be in the movie but I
have a feeling it's gonna be more of a
camp like a reserve to Cammy overall
like we'll establish who he is like oh
it's spider-man
everyone knows who spider-man is he'll
establish that he had some kind of a
friendship with Tony Stark or whatever
in the past you know another buddies but
I have a weird feeling that they're not
because he think they're not gonna turn
him into a focal point the movies still
Captain America so I think you'd even
need to establish that he knows them in
anyway because this is gonna be the
first time in a Marvel Cinematic movie
where a person where a superhero is
going to have a secret identity hmm yeah
think about liver and Civil War he
exposed to secret identity later man
will actually be the only one who has a
stake in the superhero Registration Act
and so it could be that like maybe
spider-man helps Captain America Iron
Man fight something and then he
befriends both of them and it's because
of spider-man's need for secrecy that
Captain America will kind of lean
towards the like anti-registration act
like that could he could be like the
linchpin of the movie
long without him actually being like a
main fighter of the like I mean well I
will tell you this if they reveal his
origin his is that he pull it off I
knowing Sony there will be a brand new
day movie here's another really cool
concept though because I know Sal
remember this and amazing spider-man
number two I think like the the original
solo series of spider-man had he died
and tried to join the Fantastic Four
yeah and they were like get out of here
Avengers that's exactly what I was
thinking because apparently they're
saying that like like we're telling
tales out of school here I feel like
there's a rumor and I can say this
that's not being a spoiler because it's
a rumor we don't know that like they're
changing up the roster after the after
age of Ultron that like after age of
Ultron the the Iron Man Captain America
Thor like Holy Trinity is gonna get
broken up and we're not only make sense
yeah like that we're not gonna see the
original Avengers together probably
until infinity war if that's the case
it'd be great to see spider-man go to
like cats like Iron Man let's say he
goes to stark tower and he's like hey
guys like I'm ready to join and they're
like there are no more Avengers like he
shows up at the time you can't join
anything there's no Avengers he's like
what reference to him like being added
in later it's like did I miss everything
like up pretty much like you missed all
that you missed the whole marvel
cinematic revolution I was gonna say my
theory is with the whole you know the
Netflix Marvel shows like daredevil Luke
Cage Jessica Jones etc like I think the
only reason why they're doing that now
is because they need more characters for
Civil War easily so since they're in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I think this
is an easier way than pumping out you
know a daredevil movie Iron Fist movie
so this is just an easy way to
transition them in okay and I mean the
teaser trailer I personally think looked
amazing so flare devil wanna looks yeah
by all means use that I only can play
with the daredevil teaser is simply I
really hope that we don't stretch out
the I'm in training I'm not daredevil
costume for the entire series all season
I bet it's the whole first season well
well they said the I think the director
or writer I don't know one of the heads
up for the show said that by the end of
the series he will be wearing the
classic red costume so but although I
think it's kind of cool though because I
think I was talking to Sal a while ago
about it when they saw a teaser picture
for it where they're using the Man
Without Fear costume yeah well you know
Frank Miller's so I think that's really
cool it's a it's frickin Frank Miller
who wouldn't want to see an Omaha the
Frank Miller it's also a throwback I
think we talked about this like if you
liked the old Incredible Hulk TV show
they made these movies in one of them
the trial of the Incredible Hulk I
believe daredevil appears and he's
wearing that costume like the black in
training costume so it's also kind of an
homage like the first time that
daredevil ever appeared in a movie see
my only concern is that by having the
black costume that means we're gonna
have I think it's like a 13-episode art
yeah Jean episode arc of training oh
yeah and I'm getting to the point where
I'm just not caring about training and
origins anymore like training his
daredevil me I mean the reality is like
it could be considered training where
he's like I'm not good enough and like
stick just kicks the crap out of him all
throughout like the reality is like
daredevil will be using his radar sense
to kick the crap out of villains and
fighting the kingpin that is daredevil
so we're gonna get as much daredevil as
like you'd expect just he'll probably be
like really down on himself until the
end of the series or for a season
hopefully that's actually it reminded me
you're bringing up daredevil reminded me
of a poll I saw today in which people
were saying what Marvel Cinematic
character do you want to see spider-man
team-up with first and the number one
when I saw it last was Captain America
but the second one was daredevil oh and
I would love to see that and I know in
my heart of hearts were not at least not
for the you know in via not right away
yeah like because they're done they're
also shot during what's done but like
season two I feel like they're like I
think they would be like
why would we take this billion-dollar
franchise character and put him in our
like really grim and gritty you know
crime drama Netflix series III don't
know I I would love to see it but I feel
like it's it's it's it's too greedy it's
too for us as comic-book fans who are
like man we're told we're never gonna
see this and then seeing it now and
getting everything we've ever wanted
basically it's a little it's almost like
too much whatever thought we're gonna
get gonna get Inhumans movie this
spider-man movie actually interestingly
now you know how it transitioned it
pushed everybody they just pull rope
nope everybody's everyone back my term
is coming out July 2017 and they're like
but that's when I never what's coming
out I think it was Captain Marvel oh no
that's later it's uh it's coming out on
November 2000 remember second 2018 it's
or Ragnarok to Iraq Iraq comes out
November 2017
okay you guys like a list like whatever
movie was coming out on July 2017 they
were like no it's not that spider-man
and every movie they just every movie
took the place of the last one and the
last one down the line is Inhumans in
2019 I think in like November 2019 and I
feel like that's brilliant planning on
Marvel's part because they're like 2019
and this four years away what can happen
la can happen in four years put into
uploaders x-men apocalypse could really
fail and then we won't need the Inhumans
anymore yeah I see I don't see them
backing out of the Inhumans at this
point because they've established him in
the TV show use it and you know what
they're perfect for agents of shield and
they can have all the Inhumans they can
have the Eternals and the turtles can
join like Cersei and you know the other
great but you okay that direction man
let's just throw in like saturnine and
the whole versal principle really those
two all the c-listers you get on that TV
show
get on that [ __ ] doll and you can have
a whole show without him but I think
that when
now I think that if apocalypse failed
and if like nobody goes to see the new
Wolverine movie they'll be willing to
play ball
especially as Fantastic Four doesn't
work out and it won't depend in sports
old news guys we already talked about
their thing the South said that I really
do want to comment on um and before we
take off you know but as we're
transitioning into the the next thing
one last thing about spider-man because
they moved up for Ragnarok I think
sounds right in the sense they're gonna
be killing off characters like Thor what
with Thor Ragnarok I think it's clear
they're gonna take the The Avengers
disassembled story
I'll Kahlua Ragnarok and add a bit to
the silver screen so basically we're
gonna see Thor sacrifice himself or in
some capacity die and leave the Marvel
landscape yeah and so that's gonna make
way for like this new generation of
superheroes but I still say to this day
the Captain America Civil War is gonna
set the stage for everything that comes
after the infinity Wars event this gives
to the stage for all that stuff
well that's somewhat kind of confirmed
in a sense they they were saying that
Captain Rex Civil War is gonna be a
bigger movie than an Avengers age of
Ultron like it's gonna be like just he
massive yes so it's essentially gonna be
an Avengers movie just called Captain
America Civil War well I'm saying that
like like after in Firenze I was gonna
say my heirs no because he I don't think
he watches every single one of her
podcasts Rob is very firm belief that
the Civil War is going to completely
change the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
my argument is on the flip side is if it
was it wouldn't be Captain America Civil
War it would be Avenger civil worked
so I'm saying like it's like the movie
itself
okay what's the Captain America 3 Civil
War is gonna be Stamford Connecticut all
right it's gonna be like the debate
going along you're gonna see it's gonna
be everything we saw in like Amazing
Spider Man 538 it's gonna be you know
like all those events that we saw taking
place where it all leads up to Nitro
blowing up Stamford Connecticut I don't
think we're gonna see that at all
because we don't need to rehash the
conversation we've all had multiple
times
that's Sheridan how important do you
think civil war is gonna be
in the overall Marvel Cinematic Universe
being a Captain America movie um I think
it's gonna be pretty I mean I've missed
arising like that they might even kill
off Captain America like they did in the
comics cuz I know there's the rumors
going around with Chris Evans says he
doesn't want to like Captain America
much longer yadda yadda so then they
would give it over to Bucky which they
kind of hinted in Winter Soldier but not
really you know weird looking out the
kostadin stuff so you know he's gonna
come back so I'm wondering if they do
pull a comics and just you know let
Bucky become Captain America because he
signed up for like nine more movies yeah
so he has to appear in I'm so that I'm
like hmm those just cameos or you gonna
planning to be Captain America for a
while and then you know another three
years in they give it they do the comics
again and they bring back Chris Evans
once he's had a break because he started
playing the Captain America
apparently so III don't think it's gonna
change everything but I definitely think
there's gonna be some stuff that's gonna
play you know into infinity war and all
the other movies yeah yeah okay the uh
as far as far as issues not want to
touch this recruit before we move on to
the next topic but the the whole thing
about them potentially getting rid of
the main cast of the Avengers
I think that's simply put you can't
Chris Evans and Tony and Robert Downey
jr. and all them they can't beat those
guys forever they're gonna age in the
comic books they don't age and I think
honestly this is good with Marv how big
I think guardians is a great test
marbles just gonna start creating new
superheroes give them their like five to
ten years in the limelight and they just
wrote out a new cast they're just gonna
keep doing that while DC is just gonna
be like we've got our 20 of Superman
movie run forget it start over I'm so
worried about DC not worried okay I
shouldn't say that because they have
billions of dollars and screw them but
like the fact is like Marvel's you know
they're they're planning for 2019 and
it's fair enough because they've made
like a thousand blockbusters and they're
all awesome and fun even Iron Man 3 was
fun and but higher main through the more
than the Iron Man 3 but like the but I
feel so like if Batman vs Superman sucks
oh my gosh they're gonna reboot it again
yes they are like they're gonna throw it
all away cuz like
imagine if Ironman sucked can you
imagine a cast like Tom Selleck is domme
as Tony Stark and it just didn't work
out like like because they had weddings
they had they'd Hulk and Iron Man like
they would be like a gyro try again
later
you know this they would have just said
the interconnected universe thing
doesn't work and they would have just
moved on so like with DC they're just
like God like we just can't get the damn
car started like yeah but no like I feel
so like I'm like I'm really excited for
Batman vs Superman because hey you good
to see Batman fight Superman and B it
could change everything for DC again
yeah
but without going much morning to be
talking about this a dozen times to
excel I do want to get to the
convergence discussion about rebooting
again but and airside I didn't want to
get your opinion on this how do you feel
about them keeping motika successful TV
show Network thing going on and they're
like no it's separate we're gonna try
starting it was super girl in
Constantine and flash arrow and vixen
and they're all huge and doing well and
they're like that's a separate universe
movies are a different super for their
own universe like super girl's gonna be
separate from arrow like no no they said
that there's in the contract that she
has to show up like para like I guess
NBC doesn't or whoever has it CBS
doesn't want her to but as a part of the
contract yeah arrow and flash have to
like be the ability to take a listen
good don't screw it up how do you feel
about them keeping everything separate
yeah um I would I would have loved to
have them merge together I mean cuz
that's where it seems like everything's
going with like just comic books and
everyone's trying to make their own
universe and stuff cuz I almost feel to
was kind of off topics which you asked
me but kind of on topic like with this
whole all-new Marvel thing happening
where they're doing you know they're
merging of universes reboot whatever the
heck you want to call it like I'm almost
feel like that's they're doing that to
kind of maybe make their movies somewhat
in continuity with their comic books
like not necessarily everything that
happens a copy you know they'll go back
and forth but somewhat kind of live
within the same world just because I'll
like this in age a lot of people reading
accomplished because of the movies so
it'll be easier for them to transition
into comic books right right but going
back so
see um yeah I would like to live
together I mean it's it sucks because we
get really attached you know like arrow
and flash Danny's character so it would
be great for them to cross over into the
movies but if they did that I would have
liked them to be I said this last one
was on the podcast you like I love flash
and I love air like they're really fun
shows and some of my favorite TV shows
but if they were gonna merge the
universe with the cinematic universe I
would want the show's to be more like
higher-quality like more like a house of
cards a game of Thrones like Axl because
even because even the daredevil show for
Netflix you just by looking at it you
gotta admit that that's way bigger
production than like you know just the
cinematography alone looks better than
watch an arrow yes
yeah that's like Netflix is treating it
like almost like it's a movie that's
really long yeah I've been on record
saying I'm not a fan of agents of shield
sorry everyone I said it and I agree
that daredevil looks better quality than
agents of shield shield looks like it
could be like an Iron Man to whatever
really gets kind of fun all right
I like what Eris said like imagine
imagine like an adult Batman TV show
like Bruce Wayne's grown ass fighting is
better like let's just say they go with
Batman zero year yeah and so like it's
modeled after house of cards could you
imagine how beast that would be that'd
be so like it's like dark like a dark
Bruce Wayne season to spirit even the
even the original plan back when small
oval was happening I remember there was
a pitch for a show called Wayne anyways
yeah a show about Bruce Wayne
globe-hopping and training become Batman
even that is more interesting than what
is happening in god I gotta say one
thing about Gotham like I like it but
okay so I didn't want I don't want you
alive all the time so this morning when
I'm checking my Twitter feed and
something just the Internet's in general
and ones like the Joker the Joker I'm
like oh my god it's the Joker is the in
the episode right so before I got a hop
no podcast with you guys I was watching
it on a fox now on like I don't know
like their on-demand stuff right and I'm
like the whole episode
where'd I miss something I didn't see no
Joker they get its a teaser for next
week's episode is the whole Joker thing
I'm like you got to be kidding me
so the Internet's like it's like 30
seconds long I'm like that's the only
reason why I watch this episode
currently I would have waited till
tonight or something but I wanted to see
this Joker stuff and it was a teaser for
next week's episode and even think you
got scarecrow and he was apparently he
was really popular in that in in Gotham
he was a scarecrow
it was scarecrows dad well you know
actually cuz I watched it on Hulu so I
catch it whenever I get around to
watching Gotham and the internet blew up
like Scarecrow scared yeah I watch the
whole episode like we're scare you mean
they got that guy who's like his dad and
vaguely referenced his son yeah um
because I haven't seen I haven't seen
that trailer I actually haven't watched
Gotham for a while now didn't a
reference like the Red Hood is that who
there is Red Hood gonna be him there
isn't that there's gonna be the Red Hood
gang it showed the jokester kind of like
could he be the Joker guy yeah yeah I
got the first episode and everyone stops
talking yes so so here's a question if
they introduced the Red Hood gang are
they gonna be going with the Scott
Snyder Red Hood gang or are they going
with the Red Hood gang from Alan Moore's
run tonight cuz I actually wouldn't mind
seeing how the Joker was just kind of
like duped into his circumstance and
there's just like a victim of like some
just crappy stuff because it gives it
gives him like a really good reason to
hate that man I was gonna say from what
they teased on this little there's three
seconds I saw him he's a little like 10
year old redhead kid so I don't know two
seconds because if we do it go to the
other topic where we are actually
running way out of time because I don't
think we're gonna get to endgame I just
need to know eres what is your opinion
on the new joke or origin okay so it's
not done yet
so I I said all the time I hold all
final judgments till the end right
because for all we know there could be
some twists and for anyone listening I'm
probably gonna say wait have any of you
guys watched it all right mean read it
oh yeah you're all you're up-to-date
right so I won't do anything okay so for
any listeners we haven't read there's
probably gonna be spoilers here so yeah
the new big thing is like it's alluding
to Joker being immortal right so I I'm
mixed with it because thus far in my in
my opinion and I guess I would guess
lots of other people's opinions Scott
Snyder has done no wrong with Batman
thus far what's all like 38 issues as
far like it's been Wallace yeah yes and
eternal he's like The Godfather on
eternal right so like he hasn't put out
anything bad yet and that's basically
almost all his like witches is great all
the wake was great Americans like all
his stuff is great right I think
everyone could agree with that yeah so I
like what he's doing and I think it's
really interesting especially since it's
a new take in it and it makes sense but
at the same time if not executed right
I'm worried because it's weird to have
like he's immortal you know what I mean
like cuz then you're pulling like a
whole like Joker's racial ghoul yeah
which they kind of alluded to a little
bit you know with in the last issue
whether it's talking about the Lazarus
pits and all this stuff and he's been
around forever and he's and all the
pictures and whatnot the stuff that is
the Lazarus Pit is in his spot yeah
exactly so that could be cool though I
mean if he's you know he's responsible
cuz he is like the villain for Batman
right so if the stuff analyzer spit is
in him then that basically means he's
kind of responsible for some of the
Batman's as our greatest villains you
know what I mean so he is like the root
of evil for Batman which you know could
be really cool but at the same time it
could be really the doctor eternal
eternal you know like if you look at
like Snyder's run he has dealt with
immortality throughout the whole series
and like his first bad guy was the court
of owls who have established like
predate Batman and like our Gotham
that's a quality shown a heck storyline
yeah it hasn't got a great execution but
like making Joker predate Batman like
I'll always like the idea of the Batman
in Joe
are like yin and yang and they created
they were create around the same time
and they've been around like if you make
joke or predate Batman and make him pre
like have him predate Gotham itself like
you know doing that again like another
character who Batman like never
understood properly and has been around
longer than Batman and will be around
long after Batman's dead like doesn't
that undermine Batman a little bit if
you make like his greatest villain who
was like on his same level like I I like
the idea and I really like the execution
and I'm I love the concept and the
implications of thereof but like I feel
like we just had a story where Batman
found out that he was not Gotham like
that was already epic and by the way
endgame is epic know the idea that like
Joker is so I lost it but I'll get back
to it yeah I agree
and honestly I actually liked the
concept behind this because Joker's
always had like an air of
supernaturalism around him like has
never never done anything but there's
some stuff that he's done and they even
commented on it and does it the family
like we don't know how he does some of
the stuff he does he's just there right
or he just gets to places we don't
understand him Bruce you need to explain
this and they and even even before
Scott's never started alluding to
there's more to the Joker he's always
been kind of like that like how did you
get here how did you notice what are you
doing and how did you survive our last
encounter like yeah holy smokestack are
off a cliff or you know into the sea and
like he always comes back completely
fine I never never seen how it happened
just tell Scott or whatever you know and
that's how come I kind of liked this
because it explains all it it gives an
explanation to everything and at the
same time it doesn't add anything more
to him it just explains how it all
happened and but it doesn't it's not
like well now he can throw fire from his
hands yeah but like do we need it like
do we need to know how the Joker
survives or can we just expect him to
survive and let that be like scary
enough no see I don't like Phantom
Menace need to exist in order for us to
tell us like how Anakin and obi-wan
became friends do we know that both
all these explanations I mean like isn't
the isn't our our own interpretation or
isn't the thing that we're looking like
that we like suspect better than what it
actually will be no see I I liked I'd
like Joker as a man but yeah I like
Joker as a regular person because
because what ok here's what the Joker
represents the Joker represents the
breaking point he represents the point
at which a person's circumstance just
because becomes so extreme that they
have no choice but to just go crazy it's
the only way they can deal with it like
that's why I say Alan Moore's Killing
Joke is the best story involving the
Joker ever written like I asked minions
so like Eric is that I was I was sitting
down and said ok guys like I'm branching
out of DC Comics give me the best story
involving the Joker and they said The
Killing Joke yep and so I said ok so I
sat down and read The Killing Joke to me
that will always be the best story
involving the Joker because the whole
thing is just one bad day it was just
one guy yes whose wife died their unborn
child died and he fell into a chemical
VAT and that was it I've stated he's
immortal we don't know how bad he was
before engines that he's been around
forever right but I'm getting out idea
of an immortal I don't like the idea of
an immortal man because the Joker is
what people could possibly become I just
like the idea of of a man who's just
lost his mind so bad becomes that point
at the same time it also means that
eventually the Joker can end it means
eventually what the Joker can't be
killed off like he can die it's the fact
that he hasn't died up to this point
that I think makes him so interesting
it's like Batman right or similar to
like that so unless a vision yeah
Morrison concept of Batman where Batman
will never die because Batman is
enduring and everlasting you know what
Britta Orson was a guy the blue of
Genosha so nobody cares about time to
show how immortal he is yeah Joker being
immortal is I liked the thing that made
me the most kind of like oh that's cool
about Joker being immortal is that it
shows Batman like Batman not killing the
Joker never crossing that line that like
him being like ok I'm gonna kill the
Joker finally crack and then you imagine
that if he was immortal him just getting
back up
being like you can't kill me and having
Batman go damn it I said I compromised
my morals and I crossed this line and it
didn't even work you just gave away the
last issue right there kills him and
then he's like dope okay then let me ask
you this if Batman is effectively like a
character who can't be killed off I'm
sorry if I'd the Joker's are here too
they can't be killed off if he if he's
the amalgamation of evil yeah if he's
able yeah if he's like you know just
like an inherent version of evil just
can be cut off them what's the point of
Batman fighting the Joker why even has
any more stories well in that case you
gotta have it's just
Batman is man's spirit to rail against
that which he has no control over like
it's it's just the testament to the
human spirit of like facing
insurmountable odds
oh man that's deep man see like if you
look into it I'll you get to the state
of nature this is why this is why cracks
me up
all right guys like in order to
understand the Joker here's what you
need to do you need to go back to a
one-man painting makeup over his
mustache to preserve whatever career he
thought he had and really informed the
origins of the Joker Joker bad that
you're asking a joker bad it's pretty
bad the same like the Joker he say the
Joker like this I mean yeah this year in
the series in general save Batman as a
whole but like as much as I like it I
mean I grew up watching that syndication
like I'm sure the rest of you
and everyone else who's a comic-book
Batman fan but it's good because of
nostalgia but isn't really good because
it was made to be like you know I'm not
dogs honestly I love this series but it
was meant to be like a comedy it's you
know it's not meant to be like actually
good so it's good in the sense where I
loved it enjoyed it as a kid and still
fun to watch but it's not like that's
Batman that's like that's like can't be
Batman that brought Batman back Batman
in my opinion if we didn't have the
1990s cartoon show to really bring
Batman back to the dark side he probably
would have stayed it like kind of how
Aquaman I still not really revived from
the 1970 Super Friends
Batman probably would have still not
revived from the 1960 w you would have
you have you have Tim Burton's 89 Batman
yeah and that I mean like that is what
like Warner Bros wanted from a cartoon
show it's just that Bruce Timm and Paul
Dini liked the 30s and 70s Batman and so
they infused like the 89 Batman plus
like their favorite versions of Batman
and main this what we love today the
funny thing is eras I don't have you
know the story I'm sure you do but like
the story about how like Hollywood never
really got over Batman from 1966 and
when they were pitching Batman for 1989
they apparently wanted to make like a
live-action their own version of the
1966 Batman and they wanted to cast Bill
Murray as Bruce Wayne that's how that's
how ingrained that's that show is in the
like Hollywood world is that they were
like so yeah you want to make a Batman
movie okay like that stupid show from
the 60s right okay well we'll get Bill
Murray and it'll be like like like that
um like that dragnet movie with Tom
Hanks and Dan Aykroyd where it was like
a comedy from a serious show like that
where it's like a lot of money but it's
dumb they made a stupid dragnet movie
that was like a slapstick comedy instead
of dragging it the show learn about
dragnet like through my math class and
they have something called math net
and they were like detectives teaching
us math and it was terrible you guys
didn't watch Nick at night come on let's
talk about the big announcement
everyone's freaking out about I know
I've gotten a whole bunch of tweets I'm
pretty sure Aris because he's a DC fan
also has got a bunch but that DC is
ending though new 52 okay here's my
opinion and we can all discuss it but
here's it they so basically long story
short DC has announced that they are
ending the new 52 they are going to
relaunch like I think it's like 20 to 25
new books and they're going to have 21
continuing books what people are
freaking out saying is ending the new
video they're not rebooting anything
from what I've seen for what I'm seeing
just DC has realized this isn't new and
we don't have 52 of these anymore yeah
essentially what it seems like is there
keeping basically they're keeping like
25 bucks I think 25 or 24 so the it is
what they said they're gonna keep right
so like you're keeping Batman keep it
flash keeping Greenland Kim you jostle
you keep it all like you're your
moneymaker books the ælis characters
right but then other stuff like I know
new guardians is going out a bunch of
other titles are being cancelled so it
seems like the ones the 25 they're
keeping are gonna be still stay with new
52 continuity nothing's gonna change
you're gonna keep going the writers and
artists are gonna finish the storylines
do new ones but with the new ones from
what I read and I've been hearing at
least it seems like they're gonna use it
Danah do said they're gonna use it to
experiment essentially so like for
instance one of the new books is gonna
be a bizarro book which is gonna be like
more of a comedy and like kid-friendly
and you know so they want to offer
something for every demographic and like
people who like you know funny comics
serious comics horror comics and they're
gonna do this with a lot of stuff and
then they're also going to use it as a
platform to test things to see what work
like giving cyborg
you know a new comic Queens own series
Martian Manhunter it's all gonna start
number one and then I'm sure if they're
successful they'll keep them so it seems
like it's gonna be just so it's gonna
give them 20 or so titles to play with
and do whatever the experiment with
while they keep the core books it's a
you know for all the hardcore fans to
just continue continuity yeah right one
thing
a lot of people don't realize and I
don't know if you follow it eros but I
follow like the sales in the comics
because kind of how I decide what I'm
gonna make videos on good which is
convenient cuz I'm normally reading like
the top 20 on the list anyway but a lot
of the books that DC's cancelling if
they're like in the bottom like 150 to
200 on sales like no one cares about
these books if they wanted to why why
are they so afraid of using the web as a
platform for books that have a core
audience that would make money but they
just can't afford to print like why not
make like I know that they're doing what
they did like with Batman Beyond they
had like a digital only show series I
think injustice was originally digital
only like take some of these books that
have like a huge core audience and just
put them out is like either do that go
the the thrill bent method and make them
web comics where's one page a day or
week and it's free but there's ads or
make them digital comics that are
digital only and if you see like an
upswing in sales then you just make it a
print book like and I think they should
cut it down even more like there's 25
books cut to 10 no no I like like 5 or
10 as digital-only whoops okay but see
here your comics for you here's here's
reproduce a little like I am DC's target
demographic right yeah I never really
read them I mean my dad was a huge DC
family that's how we got into it the
more I read DC the more I enjoy with the
problem is this I only care about some
characters because are some characters
that I've just always known of like in
truth like I didn't know about all the
different versions of the Green Lantern
uploading story for you guys later if we
have time that's all back to you stuff
like that like there's
like I know I mean I know who Batman is
I know who Superman is out over the
Joker is like I know these characters
when I used to watch Batman the Animated
Series like I know that in Batman
ministerially have whenever so called
red claw know who the hell that is but I
know I know of these characters because
I've just always known them like I was
born and then I read pop culture and
then I knew who they were because
they've just always been there but a lot
of the smaller characters in the books
that aren't selling just cuz I don't
know who they are and because I don't
know who they are why would I go out and
buy them like I know that this Superman
is still working on that I know the
Superman is established I know that if I
go and I buy a Superman story I'm gonna
know that at some former capacity with
issue number one like Jonathan and
Martha Kent are gonna be tied into it I
know in some former fashion he's gonna
be from the planet Krypton the planet
blew up and he landed on earth I know in
some way that I believe you well maybe a
different version different Martha and
Jonathan Kent are not in the book when
the series starts he's less emo now I
like it better now it'll be when they
bring them back they will be dead with
the fact remains that in some fashion
they played a role in his life like like
this that's them that's the run of
Superman it's been that way since the
1930s for Superman number one when you
know Shuster and Siegel went back I said
okay guys let's just start making new
stuff like this listen mate let's give
some man his own solo series you know
and in DC Comics head have added so for
me like those characters are established
Bruce Wayne his parents got shot he
became like oh my god what am I gonna do
it's like I know what I'm gonna do I
want to turn into a giant bat
they didn't notice all the series was
they were just like let's try and make
$100 this week and sell this stupid
character okay do you know why do you
know why Superman got his own solo
series super Ram was never initially
supposed to get his own solo series
actually comics number one sold like
hotcakes
and what's-his-name when Gary Conway I
think his name was had gone to the
stands and he was asking a kid like why
are you buying these stories you said
because it has Superman
that's why Superman number one got his
own solo series but nonetheless like I
know of these characters I know a lot
about these characters because there are
established characters so now you know
but nonetheless like all by those
stories a lot of the story that are at
the bottom of the list on DC's selling
charts because people like me don't know
who they are and don't have a reason to
buy them yeah that's that's little
reason behind that line of logic I see
my little so I mean we're pretty much
establishing that over all the new 52
universe and I said this early on with
the newbie too when they were talking
well what if they reboot it again and
Sal and I both agreed we're like they
spent way too much money to revamp have
anything to just throw it out that's
getting yours I think you got us on that
kid because the last discussion we had
about that yeah yeah they just they're
like action figure line alone yeah he's
like 100 figures since the time and then
the marketing look crazy like I was in
the dollar store the other day and even
the dollar store pictures of Superman
about me now our new 52 costumes yeah so
it's just like it's the new pop Funko
things there those are the new 52 ones I
just basic stuff the Batman Superman ice
took cake toppers an ice cream store
yesterday and they were Batman and
Superman from the new 52 yeah no wonder
where that's always you know what's
funny that is the way we know of its do
bicha to our preview to if they have
their underwear they've they're
wrestling suits on the outside well I
remember I said no underwear on an
episode of variant and so in the
comments was like excuse me all their
trunks not underwear just as strong men
from the 30s hello Bobby and it's also
gonna close out I think so eras can so
hold on we don't know anything else like
the Spider Man cameo spider-man's in the
Marvel Universe we know nothing
yeah DC's not ending the new 52 they're
just dropping the moniker and half the
books are gonna be restarted we don't
really know if they're gonna be in the
universe or not or what they're gonna do
yeah
so we don't really know what I mean
honestly I find a weird that we're gonna
have Harley Quinn and Harley Quinn Power
Girl although that we the
list arc ever yeah I don't know if
anyone else read that did you read
errors no I know not the the power girl
arc I have it sitting I'm behind on our
leak when I play so I'm like that's joke
I'm Way behind on but I insomnia and
that's kind of what we're establishing
night like everyone's freaking out like
oh it's ending well if you have you been
reading it if it - you know they're not
ending it they are way too many stories
happening right now for them to just say
we're done that's the end of that you
know that well that's what I'm saying I
know they for Free Comic Book Day when
they do all this convergence you know
all type of stuff they were even saying
that there's gonna be a page in there or
pages in there that's gonna preview
Scott Simon Greg Capullo the next thing
or sequel to the next thing so it's like
it's still gonna continue they're not
getting rid of it guys it's just I think
yeah they'll clean it up a little I
think though they'll clean up the
timeline and I think they'll bring back
the Kent's and I think they'll just do
they'll like it like new 52 was like
experiment for them and they're gonna go
like okay what worked what didn't and
what do people what did people say they
wanted in the beginning but what are
people still saying that they wanted
yeah I don't respond to fan criticism
and fan reaction because like that's
like four that's like two percent of
your buyers but like who like what is a
complaint they've always had or what the
what's a complaint that always can't
increases that we get and like fix that
because that's a great opportunity for
that I think like you think you fix the
Robins or they could fix like the you
know Superman being a [ __ ] or cuz
he's a weirdo now no family anybody mo
Superman is not emo like I mean he is in
this book but I mean like Superman is I
know him Superman chain is actually not
terrible like I don't like I feel like
you pull this one out is my like
de-facto yeah I love like Geoff Johns is
and ramita Junior's run on Superman I
don't look like me the record you
already know what happens in it like
that's it yeah the book opens up with it
we're angry that's it I like what Jon's
how Jon's handles Superman slash Clark
Kent not a big fan of hermidas art in
this book I love
Jr normally but I didn't like it this
time but uh but like I feel like
Schneider and Geoff Johns are the only
ones that really have been handling
Superman kind of really appropriately
lately like I don't know this is me
anyway like we're saying just like
despite anything we don't have very much
information you know I actually did
manage to work in the whole Joker origin
thing with with airs so Aris since we're
coming to the end because they do
normally wrap this up about an hour and
a half in and I think we're coming to we
have about 20 minutes left what's your
story well you guys were green cords and
I this past weekend recently went to a
fan days Comic Con in Irving Texas or
Dallas Texas right anyway they had it
they had a Stephen Amell was there they
had a bigelf Romero and Marilyn Romero
so they had like some of the the big the
big casts from era right cuz they had a
panel so I'm in the panel and I'm just
I'm listening to them and a fan comes up
and asked he's like if you could be in
any Lantern Corps what core would you be
in and you know Stephen Amell was kind
of like you know he clearly on his face
he doesn't know what the lantern cores
are right she said she said prior he did
say he's like he goes look I like comic
books but I'm more of you know from the
cinematic universe and TV shows you know
I read arrow because that's my character
and I enjoy it but I don't really read
other comic books so he said that like
20 minutes prior so everybody knows he's
in he's an actor anyway right so so he
asked him this and and then the he
didn't know so the the guy send the
question goes come on your DC you should
know this and the whole crowd kind of
goes and you see this face like on
stephen amell face like you little but
he can't you know Carey I'm gonna say
beige just to make you mad I got one
more question I got one more question
he's like okay shoot he's like if you
could be any villain
who would you be and he's like Ra's al
Ghul and then the kid goes why
previously just so everyone knows he
answered this question also like ten
minutes earlier so Stephen o goes well
if you were paying attention you would
have heard and then the whole audience
and then like it kind of got awkward so
basically I'm just kidding yeah Rochelle
cool Hey and that was my little story
guys we do here at the weekly poll we do
Elaine applause thank you classy folks
we keep it classy but it's fun I was
just gonna I was just gonna segue into
the next thing yes that's fine I'm only
think okay well is gonna segue the next
thing that would have helped if we gave
eras like the plan so um actually I
wanted to go everyone fit last thing
though real quick with it on one of
these since we have the time here um why
don't we discuss the daredevil thing
because that's the most recent thing
before all of this the show three men
implode having a total obviously this
daredevil is gonna follow Frank Miller
but what I want to see is I want to just
just even if it's only in the first 20
minutes or when he first like takes on
the role of daredevil I want to see the
classic Stanley Jack Kirby yellow red
and black outfit cuz I think it just
kind of be a cool homage to the original
daredevil the way they wrote his
character and then like you know once
he's like okay this college I mean you
can say like you know this this outfits
stupid and then actually like go to the
actual you know the black or I guess the
red daredevil costume but um you know I
think one of the coolest things about
this one of the things I love the most
about frame that was Ron daredevil was
just how much he changed the character
about how he made a more dynamic more
sinister a darker character and I'm
really hoping it would they bring to the
table with this whole thing on Netflix
and look like it's gonna be that way
that it's gonna does it arc
so oh yeah look sweet that's all I'd say
bad looks like so can someone explain to
me how a guy who's supposed to be
creeping around in the night
beating people up is doing it in yellow
I don't like is there a reason why the
original Dino it's yellow the original
bit no yeah he does the original
daredevil made a costume yellow from
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby it was yellow
and black because it was modeled after
his father's boxing costume is this the
red yeah but you don't know black Gillan
red he was originally his father is see
this is why Frank Miller's so important
the way was originally written by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby a daredevil was a guy
who was brought up by his father who was
a former boxer and so on and he was
taught of good morals as stuff like that
but his father got in a bad way they got
broke he got into a fight with a guy
kind of what his name is he was some
kind of a mob boss but he was he was
boxing on his behalf and he was told to
throw the fight and he didn't he said he
wouldn't do it because his son was in
the audience and so what he ended up
doing was he got herself killed like the
mob boss had him killed because refused
to throw the fighting cost him money and
so as a result daredevil dons I guess
ree-ree imagines his dad's costume as
one that he can wear for himself running
around as daredevil and that was the
first I don't know four six issues until
Gene Colan I think took over and changed
it in issue number seven and actually
gave him the red costume see I like the
red costume I've never been a huge
daredevil fan I openly have said that on
my channel the only stuff we've done
with daredevil has been handled by the
guy who helps me with some of these
scripts to Jason but I've always
wondered about the yellow and why like I
knew it was from his father but I just
didn't know if like was there ever a
point where everyone said hey let's go
hide at night in bright yellow yeah no
no initially like he had some measure of
like I guess what do they call that
echolocation like he had some measure of
that but it wasn't nearly like what it
became like when Frank Miller took over
he expanded that on in several ways and
made a huge but with fright Miller I
think it was Frank Miller like her
nominee was Walt Simonson it was one of
those two guys but that's when we saw
stuff like a lecturer being introduced
those gene cones run but a Miller Miller
invented Elektra
okay and then he/she was killed off in
the same kills and then killed her again
but yeah like like Miller Miller is too
daredevil what Chris Claremont was to
the x-men basically like he just totally
revamped at all there you go I mean
outside of what they're gonna do with
them Paris like do you know much of the
history on him yeah I like I mean he's
not one of the characters I've read a
lot but uh I read a little bit of him in
the 90s I don't add like I haven't kept
up with him currently I mean I read the
Mark Waid run before Marvel now yeah so
that would that was great I mean almost
everything Mark Waid does is fantastic
but I called the JJ Abrams of the
complications I just like to come for
some reason I always compare like like
complex the movies just because yeah
these are more Universal always but yeah
exactly so but no yeah I like their
novel he's not like one of these not
like in my top 10 favorite characters or
anything but I'm really excited to see
him you know get some love because I
like that all these like be Lister
c-listers whatever because are getting
love because it's just like it's tough
we would dreamed of because we knew
eventually you know Spiderman was gonna
go to film stuff but it's like until
like the last couple years we never
thought we were gonna get like an iron
fist I am excited about I cuz I've never
done anything about him when they
announced the show I'm doing I'm doing
the defenders episodes to kind of match
up with a Netflix thing and when I go
like grab the Iron Fist book read their
efforts I'm like how am I not know about
this guy yeah this is a classic man he
started Heroes for Hire her started it
with a Power Man okay Jen heroes
retirement Heroes for Hire was like hey
guys she was a new team it's based on
the blaxploitation event in the 1970s
and it's like okay cool and it's like
after that it just tanked
it was ridiculous you know I'm waiting
for waiting for a damage control movie
oh my gosh TV show I want to see Doom
Patrol come on who doesn't want to see
Doom Patrol patrol or a damage control
um those shorts they used to do I would
take those you know I want to see a what
if like TV show Oh like the comic can
you imagine - that would be just a big
thing it could be like a Twilight Zone
yeah like we now take you to an
alternate idea billing it as the Marvel
Twilight Zone residuals we'll split it
with you know it's it's um this is one
of the things I really like about them
doing this Netflix series isn't
necessarily so much because they're
doing daredevil or they're doing Luke
Cage or Danny ran area those guys what
is basically doing is making like a
market for a niche group like Luke Cage
has had maybe three big events in his
lifetime one of which includes Civil War
yeah and they were all in the last ten
years yes they weren't very significant
like House of M civil Civil War and then
I guess maybe you can even go back to
Secret Invasion Secret Invasion yeah
because of because of Jessica Jones so
yeah I mean oh my god like Jarvis took
like but nonetheless like what they're
doing here is they're saying okay look
guys like there's not a huge audience
for Iron Fist let's just like Benny said
Lebanese I don't know who the hell I
earn fist wise I don't even know like
okay like let's find out who he is let's
learn and I'm gonna Rob Rob Rob is gonna
tear up just let you guys know it's okay
for us all four of us here to go buy a
book to see if it's somebody we want to
do a video on just read about this
superhero yes do you know how many there
are
like you didn't know there's 60-year
continuities like no I do careers is
okay for us to get caught up on someone
to do a video oh yeah of course like
it's so funny every times like are you
reading this and I'm like no then how
you not reading this I'm like there's
thousands titles to read
there's no way every waking hour to
reading all of them I still wouldn't be
able to read all of them people will say
that and it's like you know like in what
universe would anyone believe that like
one person knows the entire continuity
of every single superhero dude you know
why they think because why
congratulations know everything about
every Marvel comic book character ever
made and I will use you as a source but
for right now I don't [ __ ] know but
know like like but that's what I like
about this is this basically saying like
and this is this is a great way to segue
into things because with Jessica Jones
we're getting purple man which means
we're gonna see a very dark series of
stories that's cool man we're gonna see
probably so we're gonna see like some
really screwed up stories in the
beginning of the Jessica Jones series
but this allows us to segue into like
other characters and other other other
characters that can be depicted in a
real-world way but they don't have like
a huge cult follower huge following in
terms of like Iron Man or Captain
America building off of that and our
attempt to talk about daredevil I'm
gonna not talk about daredevil but also
talk about John's spin-off show and how
they're introducing Patsy Walker into
the show Hellcat is gonna be on Jesse
Jones show which who would have ever
thought that Hellcat would be enough
anything who would have ever thought
would be enemies is what I was talking
about earth spot before this alright I
love the flash TV show and I love
everything about the flash and I wore
whatever but someone I put up the video
about firestorm he's going to flash and
everyone's leaving comments to like why
don't you do Caitlin snow killer frost
or Cisco
vibin
exact reaction was wait that's killer
frost 30 comics in DC like she showed up
at issue number 2 and then it was like
the fury of firestorm and then maybe one
or two energy dies by being on the TV
show whoever thought it was vibe because
you know it's only a matter of time
before he's in costume and whatnot oh
yeah vibe like who would have thought he
was like I know like what DC did like
Little Joe cartoons about him like just
because he's like almost like a comedic
character in the sense you know just
like it's 5:00 and now I guess there's
no that's exactly say cuz the new buddy
to try to make it now they're like well
we're gonna write and since Geoff Johns
is highly involved with the flash TV
show he's like you know what vibe name
everyone oh my god it's but yeah I know
it is just an example it's funny because
the comments that caitlin snow and i'm
like killer frost and then rob hit me up
and he's like so you gonna do killer
frost next yeah likewise rude want me to
do killer frost did i miss this killer
frost movie coming out next week yeah
there's like 15 new villains that are
showing up and over the course of the
flash TV show so I was I was like man
like I'm that's gonna be pretty crazy
but these are images of Grodd his garage
showed up yet no I saw I saw another one
that's come on he's got an episode
coming up we just don't know well I
could what could happen good because he
looks great do it okay so guys I think
at this point we need to start kind of
winding down we did officially one one
hour 18 minutes and I want to let you
guys know I want to thank our guest Aris
from Berrien comics are joining us today
if you guys in ordered the one person
who lived under rock and I don't know
who very any is he's pretty much the
father of all comic book channels on
YouTube he does very high quality show
comes out every Wednesday he also does
one shots that pop up across the course
of the week when he has to do something
important but he fills you in on all
kinds of history about characters top 10
bad suits top 10 Iron Man suits which by
the way I'm still mad about you about so
I was literally writing that now I have
to do
Iron Man suits oh thanks now we gonna do
all of America's before we got a lot off
here like here's one question I have
about gorillas god this may seem like a
silly question and it's plugging his
channel can I finish I'm sorry go ahead
alright that's great stuff go check him
out at varying comics um he's I think
he's the largest comic book channel out
of all of us so um but he does a new
show which I mean I don't know maybe you
want to give them a teaser uh Aris about
tomorrow show tomorrow is actually gonna
be the history of the Speed Force the
people the people asked them at and I
had to give it to them and one of the
they wanted history of the Speed Force
which is like flashes I say all the time
like everyone's your favorite character
so I'm like I've been reading characters
comics for like more than 20 years so I
have a lot of favorite characters my
favorite use of the flash favorite
Wolf's always Green Lantern anyway but
yeah you guys who were like typing
challenged whatever it is I don't like
to type for some reason I don't
understand why you wouldn't because
everybody stopped being in the chat the
link to airs his channels down in the
description so you have to do is move
your mouse ice down and then go to the
link and then press the mouse button to
click it's and we really appreciate it
being on here now Rob what did you guys
say about garage before I talk about the
week people about net here's something I
always wondered about gorilla grodd so
gorilla grodd being a super small guy
that he is a super smart monkey has he
ever like ants might be a silly question
has he ever like thrown a spooly people
because I want to see that the latest
Aquaman run they go and find Grodd who's
in prison in the gorilla city from when
the flash beat him and the latest run
and Aquaman goes in there and you find a
garage man throwing his poo and he's
just being like guys like a little kid
he's like do like monkeys he'll do that
like if you piss them off the filter
pure here
aerosol if you read document at all how
do you be reading Malstrom what the new
Aukerman storyline Malstrom where
grodd's all captured and fighting I have
not been reading the new tonight just
boiled that if doses pou whenever he
does things later gorilla base did they
snore Mele the excuse of well he's just
throwing a garage tantrum kind of a
situation like you can't hold me I'm a
Grodd you know so far the best
incarnation of garage I think this I
think this also rivals the comics is
Justice League Unlimited yeah ours here
booth gorilla grodd oh yeah him taking
over the the the whatever Legion to do
whatever you want to call it and the
secret society I think they call it and
that scene I'm just really just because
I know Aris watched it the episode when
Lex Luthor takes the secret society from
Grodd and locks him in the airlock and
just having Clancy Brown and powers
Boothe just butt heads for just a couple
minutes is just such for me like movie
nerd casting I'm like oh my god I'm over
he goes like he says you know it could
have gone the other way it really could
have couldn't it no but why speak ill of
the dead launched into space
kale Gorilla Grodd in children's cartoon
Fe has yes Bruce Timm is the man
yep II was like you're such a Bruce Timm
fanboy I'm like yeah yeah so okay yeah
so Grodd is officially to our pool but I
so so yeah so guys guys been asked about
it we've been talking about it the
weekly pool net our our youtube our our
comic book youtuber community website
which is gonna host the the videos of
all the comic book youtubers who have
decided to participate and give you guys
a forum where you guys can all go
discuss and build this community up with
us it is on track right now - supposedly
launched about Wednesday Thursday by the
latest
should be this weekend but it is the
weekly pull dotnet also as far as us
starting to stream this on Twitch we're
still in talks but work
planning to move to a live streaming
platform be a twitch or something else
in the next two weeks so be ready to
kind of follow along and go ahead over
that direction all right guys
but the weekly poll that net is going up
and if you are been out of the loop that
is our community website we're going to
be doing articles videos from the people
and if you want to participate you want
to be a moderator in the forums or you
want to be submit articles to be a part
of the entire article basis we're trying
to build up here then contact us at
salad TV little house calm
Robert marble explain calm or comic
story in a gmail.com I am cheap and did
not buy my own domain apparently and
Betty loves comics at gmail Doug yeah
who know at msn.com
okay so thank you everybody uh do we
have anything else we got to say do you
want to say anything underway on earth
oh no I mean uh variant comics and
everyone's I put in an episode in one
shots one shots at random and yeah
tomorrow's gonna be the history of the
Speed Force so everyone who wants to
know more about the Speed Force watch
tomorrow you know probably do a better
job than I did I don't normally do this
kind of [ __ ] sales promotion but this
is something that I'm really proud of
and I think is really cool especially if
you play video games I know we were
comic group but if you haven't played
half-life you're under a rock but we we
got these in and I'm really really proud
of these are on our tee public store
there are our Black Mesa headcrabs
sports team t-shirts that we made nice
well since we're talking about our tee
public self promotion shirt all day so
if you want to go we I should just do it
like variant doesn't hit check out my
store right yeah and I think we're
somewhere in my traditional Irish
drinking team hoodie and whenever I was
recording myself on video I should start
wearing something else besides the study
it's weird we only see the top half you
anyway so it's not you only see your
head yeah you don't do like really raise
up the chair I mean there we go thank
you for joining us today as usual
how now brown cow
go ahead yourself San Diego and we'll
see you next time oh by the way if
anybody wants to get mad cuz you live in
San Diego we're on comics explained so
you can get mad at him
thanks for joining us today will be
Willie bit why can't I say it we will be
back at the same comics explain Channel
SAN conics explain tied with the weekly
pull podcast brought to you by comics
explained TV little house comics Taurean
and we're gonna drag arrows back kicking
and screaming so thank you thank you
once again for joining us eris and we
will see you guys next time right here
at the channel 4 p.m. Eastern oh wait 6
p.m. Eastern Tuesday y-yeah alright
we'll see ya later